foreign
from today I'm going to be a virgin
there are some of those they're born
again I'm gonna be a virgin now yeah and
everybody has
strategy forget it don't worry about
three grandchildren I'm a 46 year old
son I'm gonna be a virgin and I'm not
gonna and anybody else who says to me
that I'm not a virgin I'm gonna sue them
I'm gonna go to newspapers and I'm gonna
make I'll be up in arms because I am now
identifying as a virgin and I and I said
to you you have to see me as a virgin
would you feel happy about that but I
think we keep creating examples that are
not very relative to this conversation
obviously being a virgin that is a very
objective thing someone identifying as a
man or woman we've not been able to
identify it we've not been able to okay
explain what a man and a woman is